Our goal now is to solve the monkey and
the typewriter problem for
the case of spectral dictionary, and
after we solve this problem,
we will see that it will lead us
surprisingly to Ostrich Hemoglobin.
Let's start from finding the probability
that a string Peptide matches
a string started at a given
position in DecoyProteome.
And this probability is of course,
probability of Peptide, is
(1/20)^|Peptide|
Now, let's estimate
the expected number of times
Peptide appears in
DecoyProteome of length n.
To compute this number, E(Peptide,n),
we simply need to
multiply Pr(Peptide) by n.
Now, our goal is to find
the expected number of times
peptides from dictionary appear
in DecoyProteome of length n.
And this number,
E(Dictionary,n),
is simply the product of n,
length of DecoyProteome,
multiplied over the sum through
all peptides in dictionary,
probability of each individual peptide,
and this is simply denoted for
our future references,
n*Pr(Dictionary)
The question that we will be
interested in is: How many
peptides in DecoyUniprot+ are expected
to score at least -19
against DinosaurSpectrum?
I remind you that -19 is the
score of the peptide spectrum match
between DinosaurPeptide and
DinosaurSpectrum.
To solve this problem,
we will first need to solve
the following probability of
spectral dictionary problem.
Find the probability of a spectral
dictionary for a given spectrum and
score threshold.
Input is a spectral vector,
and the score threshold,
and the Output is probability
of the resulting diction.
Before this solves the Probability of
Spectral Dictionary Problem, we will solve
a slightly simpler Size of
Spectral Dictionary Problem, which is:
Find the size of SpectralDictionary, for
a given spectrum and a score threshold.
To compute the size of
a spectral dictionary,
we will introduce the variable size(i,t),
which is the number of peptides
matching i-prefix of SpectralVector,
which is s_1...s_i,
matching it with score t.
We will introduce the variable size_a(i,t),
which is the number of peptides matching
i-prefix with score t and
ending in a specific amino acid a.
Well, size(i,t) of course, is
equal to the sum through all
amino acids a, size_a(i,t).
And since removing the last
amino acid a from a peptide
results in a shorter peptide with
mass i-a and score t-s_i,
we can rewrite this expression for size
as sum through all amino acids a,
size(i-|a|, t-s_i)
And, of course,
we need to add initialization
which will be size(0,0) = 1
So, we are now
ready to compute the size of spectral
dictionary using this recurrency.
Given spectrum, let's construct
a directed acyclic graph of spectrum
on nodes 0, ..., m,
with weight(node i) = s_i.
So that will be the nodes of our graph and
I've already represented them as simply
weights that I inherited
from the spectral vector.
Let's assume that we have a toy
example of amino acids x and z
with respective masses 4 and 5.
It gives us this set of edges for
amino acid x, this set of edges for
amino acid z, and a peptide in
this case becomes simply a path in
the resulting graph from source to sink.
And labels of this path of
course spell out a peptide.
Now, the score of the peptide spectrum
match is simply the sum of the weights of nodes
on a path in the resulting graph, which
is a score of PSM. In this case,
the score is three,
after there's another pass
corresponding to a different peptide
XZX, the score will be four.
Therefore, to compute the size of spectral
dictionary, we simply need to construct
a table for computing size(i,t).
So this is an example of how we compute
values of size(i,t) in a given row-
I'm sorry, in a given column.
So in this case,
the recurrency correspond to
value s_i = one.
We continue further,
and in this case,
the recurrency corresponds to the value
in spectral reactor equal to 0.
And finally, we fill in all the table.
In this case, the final value in the last
element of the spectral vector is 2.
We have just computed the size
of the spectral dictionary,
and it turns out that computing
the probability of the spectral dictionary
is not much different.
Once again, consider a spectral vector,
s1, ..., si, ..., sn
and define Pr(i,t) as the sum of
probabilities of all peptides
matching i-prefix with a score of t.
We will also define Pr_a(i,t)
as the sum of probabilities
of all peptides matching
i-prefix with a score of t
and ending in amino acid a.
Obviously, Pr(i,t) equals
the sum of Pr_a(i,t),
and since removing the last
amino acid a from a peptide
results in a shorter peptide with
mass i-|a|,
score t-s_i, and
20 times larger probability,
we have the recurrence that is
shown at the bottom of this slide.
Please note that the only difference in
the recurrence for size(a,t) and
the recurrence for Pr(a,t)
is this term "divided by 20".
So in the case of computing size(i,t),
that was an example of recurrence,
the only difference for
the case of computing Pr(i,t)
is that we will need to divide
new entries by 20.
And now, we are ready to find
the statistical significance of
the peptide spectrum match between
DinosaurPeptide and DinosaurSpectrum.
The statistical significance under
the assumption that we search for
this peptide spectrum range in
the Uniprot database of length
approximately 200 million amino acids.
To compute this probability, I will
give you a reminder and a hint.
A reminder:
PSM(DinosaurPeptide,DinosaurSpectrum)
has a score of -19.
And hint:
if you already solved the problem of
computing the size and
probability of the spectral dictionary,
Dictionary of DinosaurSpectrum for
threshold -19 contains an astounding number
of peptides and has probability 0.00018.
Which allows us to answer the question:
How many PSMs with score at least
-19 do we expect to find in a decoy
proteome of the same size as UniProt+?
We are simply solving the monkey and
the typewriter problem, and
in this case we get an amazing number:
over 35,000.
Therefore, finding DinosaurPeptide as
an interpretation of DinosaurSpectrum
is no more surprising than the monkey
typing THE after 200 million attempts.
Actually, there is absolutely
nothing surprising
if it happened in
the monkey typing exercise.
And likewise, there is nothing
surprising in finding DinosaurPeptide
in UniProt+ database as an interpretation
of the DinosaurSpectrum.
After it turned out that some peptides
identified in the T-Rex sample
are questionable,
it became clear that all peptides reported
in the T-Rex paper have to be re-analyzed.
And there are 70 T-Rex peptides
reported in the T-Rex paper.
And after receiving criticism
upon his discovery,
John Azara released all
30,000 T-Rex spectra so
that people from all over
the world were able to analyze them.
And within a week after the release
of T-Rex spectra,
the Laboratory of Martin McIntosh at
Fred Hutchinson Cancer Research Center
in Seattle made an astonishing discovery.
They found yet another peptide
in the T-Rex sample that was
much more statistically significant
than any peptide Azara identified.
The shock was that the peptide
actually comes from Ostrich and
it's not a collagen.
It is a hemoglobin.
It would be shocking if the hemoglobin
peptide indeed came from T-Rex
because hemoglobins are much
less conserved than collagens.
Furthermore, hemoglobin peptides have
never been found in much younger
fossils, such as the bones
of extinct cave bats.
These cave bat fossils are so
common in Europe in caves that
they were used as a source of phosphate
to produce gunpowder during WWI.
Because Azara had analyzed ostrich samples
before analyzing the T-Rex sample,
could it be that the hemoglobin peptide
is a carry-over or the identification of
leftover peptides hiding inside a mass
spectrometer after a previous experiment?
Contamination is a fact of life
in every proteomics laboratory.
Mass spectrometrists are never surprised
when they identify human keratin
in their samples because
the air in any room
contains millions of tiny
human skin particles.
It doesn't matter how many
times you vacuum-cleaned it.
If the hemoglobin peptide is a carry-over,
then the entire T-Rex sample
has been contaminated,
implying that all other T-Rex
peptides should be discarded.
However, Azara maintained that
there was no contamination and
that the ostrich hemoglobin
must be a T-Rex peptide,
expanding the class of
proteins that can survive for
millions of years beyond just collagen.
If the T-Rex fossil is indeed
a treasure trove of ancient proteins,
then why we should we limit our
search to collagen peptides?
Why not do a search against all
known from all vertebrates?
Of course, you should use
criteria that are similar to ones
that Azara used, such as allowing for
up to one mutation.
If we follow this criterion,
then we would find a surprisingly
diverse array of peptides, including
mouse and human peptides.
Thus, the hemoglobin peptide
didn't help the claim about
finding molecular evidence of
the link between birds and dinosaurs:
it has weakened this claim.
And as the T-Rex peptides
paper continues to age,
there is no end in sight
to its controversy.
Yet, it was not the first paper
to report the retrieval of
genetic material from a dinosaur.
In 1994, Scott Woodward announced
that he had sequenced DNA from an 80
million year old dinosaur fossil.
The most vehement critics of his
finding was, believe it or not,
Mary Schweitzer, who proved that Woodward
had only sequenced contaminated human DNA.
The moral is that, although we often
present scientific discoveries as
clear and noncontroversial,
the reality is that many of the avenues
of modern science sometimes
fall short of this ideal.
In a sense, the academic battleground
is a part of the appeal of becoming
a scientist in the first place.
But we also cannot help but wonder
if we would have a conclusive answer
to whether Horner's fossil really
contained dinosaur peptides
if it was shared with
thousands of fossil researchers.
Fittingly, in her criticism of
Woodward's dinosaur DNA paper,
Schweitzer wrote: "Real advance in
paleontology will come only when
it is demonstrated that those studies can
be replicated in independent laboratories."